Jean-François bonsoir
Patrick qu'est-ce que ça nous dit pour
savoir ça nous fascine parce-que on les
entend mais qu'est-ce que ça nous dit
cette séquence de 19 secondes en France
même si on le voit le président
a un sourire parce que dans la limite
habituelle des Chinois il y a cette
espèce de sourire poli de prime abord
les mots sont à mon avis extrêmement
terrible de la part d'un dirigeant
chinois qui lui dit on s'était entendu
pour que vous parliez de votre version
de ce qui est arrivé en fait ce qu'il
faut rappeler simplement c'est que
Monsieur Trudeau s'en venait au sommet
du G20 et il n'avait pas de rencontre
officielles prévues avec ces jeans ping
d'ailleurs la position les conservateurs
en premier lui disait il faudrait que
vous le voyez si vous le voyez il faut
lui parler de toute cette controverse au
sujet de l'intervention chinoise dans
les élections de 2019 au Québec
visiblement le Canada donc a réussi
mardi à avoir une rencontre on le sait
parce qu'on a vu une image ou deux dans
les corridors en fait est-ce qu'un
président de Chine perfusé une rencontre
avec le Premier ministre du Canada dans
ses circonstances-là mais ce qui est
probablement un imperde diplomatique et
certainement un imperde diplomatique
important c'est que sans que les
habituellement dans un rencontre
formelle les deux s'entendent pour voir
la presse ou dire à la presse ce qui
s'est passé et on s'entend pour dire ce
qui s'est passé monsieur Trudeau a pris
l'initiative pas tellement pour la
communauté internationale mais surtout
pour le Parti conservateur pour Monsieur
Poirier pour son électorat au Canada en
disant j'ai parlé au président chinois
je lui ai parlé de de l'intervention
chinoise dans les élections et ça le
président chinois lui dit formellement
quand il le revoit dans les corridors
mais là cette fois il prend la peine il
y a une caméra qui était moins tout ça
c'est ça qui est assez inhumidité il lui
dit
on ne s'est pas entendu pour dire les
choses et deuxièmement la version de ce
que vous dites n'est pas juste c'est pas
comme ça que ça s'est passé et là
Monsieur Trudeau on le voit vraiment mal
à l'aise et là il est à dire il faut
qu'on ait des relations constructives
entre nous même si on a des différents
on peut faire des choses ensemble et
tout ça et le président chinois lui dit
peut-être mais à une condition c'est que
vous établissiez des conditions
favorables alors visiblement la Chine
n'est pas contente c'est une altercation
qui montre un peu que les relations qui
n'étaient pas déjà bonnes c'est la
première rencontre depuis très longtemps
et les relations qui étaient déjà très
bonnes en tout cas ce faux pas
diplomatique là n'aidera certainement
pas d'autant plus que en plus sur la
scène mondiale tout le monde a vu cette
scène là ça n'aide pas beaucoup l'image
d'un Canada déterminé fort etc oui parce
que Monsieur Trudeau a l'air un peu
entre au départ des condensés mais pour
les relations avec avec la Chine vous
dites c'est très mauvais pour les
affaires domestiques au Canada ça peut
être bon parce que je reçois plein de
courriel des gens qui disent on l'aime
pas mais ah il a mis ses culottes il a
arrosé au Canada
c'est ça c'est pour ça qu'il a rendu
public les grandes lignes de sa
perception de ce qui s'était passé à
cette réunion là mais ça causé ce
problème là bon
le peuple la porte-parole du ministère
des Affaires étrangères de Chine a
immédiatement réagi à Pékin en disant
que c'était pas si grave que ça je pense
que la Chine a cette minimiser cet
incident là parce que les relations vont
déjà très mal et il faut le dire je
pense la Chine est en train d'essayer de
refaire un peu son image parce que les
chinois sont très conscients que leur
image à l'étranger en tout cas dans la
grande majorité des pays du monde est
très négative et c'est pas c'est parce
que la Chine devrait souhaiter à long
terme en tout cas Jean-François il y a
eu une ébauche une nouvelle politique
canadienne envers la Chine Mélanie Joly
il y avait eu une autre ministre avant
bon bref on tente de se resituer
vis-à-vis du géant chinois qui s'est
durci vous qui avez vécu de l'intérieur
en Chine avec des entreprises
canadiennes des entreprises québecoises
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour les
prochains mois pour les pour les pour
les affaires en Chine de la part de nos
entreprises
de toute façon pour nos entreprises qui
est important c'est de savoir où se
situe le gouvernement canadien et dans
les relations canadachines il y a eu
beaucoup de flous de gaz de la part du
Canada de réactions extrêmement négative
de la part de la Chine l'enlèvement des
deux malcols qui a fait peur aux
entreprises ainsi on peut se retrouver
dans une situation où deux innocents
sont arrêtés détenus en otage pendant
presque trois ans dans des conditions
horribles et tout ça dans un différent
qui est qui est né par l'arrestation
d'une d'une carte supérieure d'une
grande compagnie chinoise ce que les
entreprises veulent à l'étranger c'est
que le Canada a une politique claire
face à la Chine et il y a de bons
éléments de ce côté là à part ce qui
vient d'arriver dans cette scène ou
cette gaffe diplomatique à mon avis de
Monsieur Trudeau madame Joly a présenté
une stratégie face à la chaîne qui va
faire partie d'une grande stratégie
Indo-Pacifique qui va qu'on va connaître
au cours des prochains mois c'est
important et les choses qu'elle a dites
sont importantes il faut s'affirmer à la
Chine il ne faut plus avoir honte
dit-elle de défendre nos valeurs
défendre nos intérêts commerciaux donc
il faut se tenir face à la chute il y a
cette volonté aussi du Canada avec ses
alliés de dire la Chine madame Joly
d'ailleurs l'a dit en mots très clair la
Chine est un élément perturbateur dans
le monde alors les alliés du Canada
disent face à ces éléments perturbateurs
comme la Russie en est un extrêmement
fort ces temps-ci mais la Chine aussi
dans certains de ses comportements dont
on appuie à la Russie qui est plus
mitigé maintenant la face à ces gens-là
est-ce qu'on devrait pas avoir une
stratégie où on privilégie davantage les
pays qui partagent les mêmes valeurs
dans nos rapports commerciaux et tout ça
c'est ça qu'on essaie de dire dans la
politique de madame Joly face à la Chine
on essaie de dire aux entreprises vous
connaissez nos médecins face à la Chine
vous y allez on espère que vous allez
respecter nos valeurs et puis on va vous
aider à ouvrir des pour que vous ayez
d'autres opportunités Jean-François
Lépine merci beaucoup à très bientôt
bonne soirée très claire merci